look daelin tonight you need to make a  decision who's this you have three  options Iowa State located on Broadway  Street Notre Dame on West Jefferson  Avenue in Michigan State the alleyway  off Rush Street there are five minutes  on the clock for your commitment you  must reach one of the three locations  before time expires make your decision  daily  molded by a city where nothing is given  I'm blessed to have the opportunity  millions good stream  my family has made me the man I am today  my coaches made me the player I am too  no one's expectations will surpass model  I have yet to scratch the surface  trust in the Lord with all your heart  and we not on your own understanding in  all your ways submit to and he will make  your paths straight  God country nutter that  rollers